espèce d'idiot tu ne sert vraiment à
rien il va nous falloir des semaines
pour ouvrir un nouveau puits je suis
vraiment désolé si vous me laisse mans
hors de question que je te laisse faire
stone's comment je veux te le dire en
sumérien on étrusque cette équipe
rassemble les archéologues les plus
prestigieux de toute la planète et les
plus brillants et les plus cool tout le
contraire de toi bon ok c'est jusque là
dessous il n'y a aucune écoute et
c'était un accident nous étions sur le
point de trouver enfin le trésor du roi
pacal alors le propre à sa défense
excusez moi mais il ya aucune trace de
trésors le tsoup il est juste sarcophage
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment as tu pu nous convaincre
d'emmener avec nous cet amateur
incapable de faire la différence entre
des symboles égyptien et précolombien à
son âge il n'a même pas encore obtenu
son diplôme d'archéologie oui peut-être
mais j'ai vécu des aventures qui m'ont
appris bien plus qu'un diplôme auquel
aventure peux tu s'il te plaît nous
éclairer à ce sujet
j'ai
tué un danger pour l'archéologie tu es
viré coup et n'oublie pas d'emmener ce
chien et ce satané perroquet avec toi
qu'est-ce que vous avez reproché à
bernardo ils mangent mais farid a pas de
l'explorateur et la table des brawn au
cinéma le 24 août
vous vous en faites pas on trouvera le
coupable
centrale ici l'agent ramirez contrôler
les caméras de surveillance voulez vous
la seule chose qu'il y à contrôler ici
c'est mon cholestérol
excusez moi vous êtes cia agence
spéciale 5 pickles c'est moi qui dirige
cette opération vous êtes guadalupe
ramirez services secrets mexicain et
c'est moi qui dirige les enquêtes
attendait mais c'est votre carte de
bowling et alors vous aimez pas le
bowling ou détesté tout ce qui est
américain c'est ça le mexique c'est
aussi l'amérique est bien sûr et le
chili aussi n'importe quoi et c'est ma
plaque rend dès la mois
mais la vôtre négatif elle est tombée
dans les toilettes
[Musique]
perdre tous vos supérieurs m'ont confié
l enquête rendez moi ma plaque et
j'en étais rue où on a affaire à un
gamin de 8 ans croit rêver
excusez moi et savez-vous à qui
appartient ses salades l'explorateur et
la table d'émeraude où le cinéma de 24
août les
bienvenus professeur victoria moon
chercheuse en sciences occultes
vous avez une terrible raz laissez-moi
la vérifier laissez-moi la cua feu
vous voilà pur maintenant attendez vous
êtes victoria moon de mystère tv
diffusion h24 deux phénomènes
paranormaux de projection astrale et de
mystères inexpliqués
deux siècles plus tard l'énigme demeure
dans le monde spirituel ce soir dans
tête à tête avec les squelettes nous
demanderons à van gogh où il a caché son
oreille et n'oubliez pas le monde
visible n'est qu'un fragment du monde
existant moi
[Musique]
tout ça est très très intéressant vous
fatiguez pas je sais bien que j'ai une
mauvaise réputation parmi les
archéologues mais il ignore le fait que
notre monde est rempli de phénomènes
étranges qui dépasse la raison de
l'explorateur et la table d'émeraude au
cinéma le 24 août
regarde ça jeff
qu'est ce que ça fait au mexique
un sarcophage égyptien
gênantes ou pas
est-ce que ça va très bien j'ai vraiment
aucun risque
tu es viré
bave revient
pour allah 15 des pauses et animaux me
sens hier la paire avec de nouveaux amis
ramona non il y à des pauses à respecter
pour de nouvelles aventures
bon quelle équipe de choc qu'est ce que
tu as fait à mona lisa je les corriger
alors quoi quand je suis revenue des gaz
et il est salué par le de mohéli
alors là bravo c'est la momie la plus
riquiqui que j'ai jamais
ah ah
comme
tu es maudit ce genre de se retirer
permanence il n'est pas brisé
cet explorateur et la table d'émeraude
c'est super cool au cinéma le 24 août